a line passes through the points
negative three six and six zero find the
equation of this line in point-slope
form
slope-intercept form standard form and
the way to think about these these are
just three different ways of writing the
same equation so if you give me one of
them we can manipulate it to get any of
the other ones but just so you know what
these are
point-slope form let's say that X let's
say the point x1y1 are it let's say that
that is a point on the line and when
someone puts this little subscript here
so if they just write an X that means
that we're talking about a variable that
could take on any value if someone
writes X with a subscript 1 and a y with
a subscript 1 that's like saying a
particular value X a particular value of
x and a particular value of y or
particular coordinate so and you'll see
that when we do the example but
point-slope form says that look if I
know a particular point and if I know
the slope of the line then putting that
line in point-slope form would be Y
minus y1 is equal to M times X minus x1
so for example and we'll see do that in
this in this video if the point negative
3 comma 6 is on the line then we'd say Y
minus 6 is equal to M times X minus
negative 3 so it'll end up becoming X
plus 3 so this is a particular X and a
particular Y it could be a negative 3 &
6 so that's point slope form slope
intercept form is y is equal to MX plus
B where once again M is the slope B is
the y-intercept where does the line
intersect the y axis what value does y
take on when x is 0 and then standard
form is the form ax plus B y is equal to
C where these are just two numbers
essentially they really don't have any
interpretation directly on the graph so
let's do this let's figure out all of
these forms so the first thing we want
to do is figure out the slope once we
figure out the slope then point-slope
form is actually very very very
straightforward to calculate so just to
remind ourselves slope slope which is
equal to M which is going to be equal
to the change in Y over the change in X
now what is the change in Y if we view
this as our endpoint if we view this if
we imagine that we're going from here to
that point what is the change in Y well
we have our endpoint which is zero y
ends up at zero and why was it six so
they are finishing Y point is zero our
starting Y point is six what was our
finishing x point or x-coordinate our
finishing x-coordinate was six let me
make this very clear I don't want to
confuse you so this zero we have that
zero that is that zero right there and
then we have this six which was our
starting Y point that is that six right
there and then we want our finishing
x-value that is that six right there or
that six right there and we want to
subtract from that we want to subtract
from that our starting x-value
well our starting x-value is that right
over there that's that negative three
that's that negative three and just to
make sure we know what we're doing this
negative three is that negative three
right there I'm just saying how much did
if we go from that point to that point
our Y went down by six right we went
from six to zero ry-ry went down by six
so we get zero minus 6 is negative six
that makes sense why went down by six
and if we went from that point to that
point what happened to X we went from
negative 3 to 6 it should go up by 9 and
if you calculate this take your six
minus negative three six minus negative
three that's the same thing as 6 plus
three that is nine and what is negative
6 9 so well if you simplify it it is
negative 2/3 you divide the numerator
and the denominator by 3 so that is our
slope negative 2/3 so we're pretty much
ready to use point-slope form we have a
point we could pick eat one of these
points I'll just go with the negative 3
6 and we have our slope so let's put it
in point-slope form so point point-slope
form point-slope
form all we have to do is we say why -
now we could have taken either of these
points I'll take this one so Y minus the
Y value over here so Y minus 6 is equal
to is equal to our slope which is
negative 2/3 negative 2/3 x times X
minus our x-coordinate well our
x-coordinate so X minus our x-coordinate
is negative 3x minus negative 3 and
we're done we can simplify a little bit
this becomes Y minus 6 is equal to
negative 2/3 times X X minus negative 3
is the same thing as X plus 3 this is
our point-slope form now we can
literally just algebraically manipulate
this guy right here to put it into our
slope intercept form let's do that so
let's do slope intercept in orange so we
have slope slope intercept slope
intercept so what can we do here to
simplify this well we can we can
multiply out the negative 2/3 so you get
Y minus 6 is equal to I'm just
distributing the negative 2/3 so
negative 2/3 times X is negative 2/3 X
and then negative 2/3 times 3 is
negative 2 and now to get it in
slope-intercept form we just have to add
the 6 to both sides so it gets so we get
rid of it on the left hand side so let's
add 6 to both sides of this equation
left-hand side of the equation we're
just left with the Y these guys cancel
out you get a Y is equal to negative 2/3
X negative 2/3 X negative 2 plus 6 is
plus 4 so there you have it that is our
slope-intercept form MX plus B that's
our y-intercept now the last thing we
need to do is get it into the standard
form get it into standard form standard
so once again we just have to
algebraically manipulate it so that the
X's and the Y's are both on this side of
the equation so let's just add 2/3 X to
both sides of this equation so let me
well I'll start here so we have y is
equal to negative 2/3 X plus 4 that's
slope-intercept form let's add 2/3 X so
plus 2/3 X plus 2/3 X to both sides of
this equation plus 2/3 X I'm doing that
so I don't have this 2/3 X on the right
hand side this negative 2/3 X so the
left hand side of the equation I scrunch
it up a little bit maybe more than I
should have
the left hand side of this equation is
what it is 2/3 X because 2 over 3x plus
this Y that's my left-hand side is equal
to these guys cancel out is equal to 4
so this by itself we are in standard
form this is the standard form of the
equation if we wanted to look make it
look extra clean put no have no
fractions here we could multiply both
sides of this equation by 3 if we do
that what do we get 2/3 x times 3 is
just 2 X Y times 3 is 3 y and then 4
times 3 is 12
these are the same equations I just
multiplied every term by 3 if you do it
to the left hand side you can do it to
the right hand side or you have to do to
the right hand side and we are in
standard form